during this time folks here's all I'm  saying Andy Grove I'm going to keep  saying this as many times as possible  who ran a company called Intel that grew  a hundred percent rate that everybody in  Silicon Valley swore by this Hungarian  guy that built one of the best stories  in Silicon Valley he wrote a book and  the book was called only the paranoid  survive simple as that and too many  people are not paranoid today I'm gonna  do great people are good only the  paranoid survive so you need a little  bit of that mindset of only the paranoid  survived today because if you don't in a  market tanks because here's what happens  if Dave Ramsey is right guess what  nothing changes great he's right but if  Dave Ramsey is wrong a lot of people who  listen to him are screwed because they  sat there saying the Market's not going  to crash he didn't prepare them to say  it could potentially happen